Y
NEWS AGENCY BOOK ON IN AWE AT
THE REPORTERS OF "VOGUE"
MAGAZINE IN NEW YORK.
THE VOGUE GUYS TO STALINISM THE
OLD-FASHIONED WAY, THEY ARE ALL
IN.
THEY BARELY USE VERBS, IT'S ALL
SMOLDERING HOT SUPERLATIVES.
CONSIDER THE NEW VOGUE PROFILE
OF DR. JOE BIDEN, THE SCHOLAR,
SCIENTIST, STATES PERSON, CIVIL
RIGHTS ICON, HEALER, MOTHER OF A
NATION, THE FIRST LADY OF OUR
HEARTS, WE COULD GO ON, BUT
VOGUE ALREADY DID.
DR. JOE WE LEARN IS DRIVEN,
EFFORTLESSLY POPULAR, BUT ALSO
SOMEONE WHO REMINDS US OF
OURSELVES.
THAT'S RIGHT, SHE'S US.
BUT BETTER.
AS VOGUE PUTS IT, SHE'S EVERY
INCH OF GODDESS.
A VERY BUSY GODDESS.
AT ONE POINT, WE FIND DR. JILL
IN READING GLASSES ON
AIR FORCE ONE PREPARING FOR HER
NEGOTIATIONS WITH OTHER WORLD
LEADERS.
YOU GO, DR. JILL, YOU DON'T NEED
TO BE ELECTED TO LEAD OUR
COUNTRY.
BACK IN THE UNITED STATES,
DR. JILL BARELY PAUSES TO GET
INTO A GLAMOROUS OUTFIT BEFORE
ADMINISTERING LIFE-SAVING
VACCINES TO ANY AMERICAN WHO
WANTS ONE AND SOME WHO DON'T.
DR. JILL IS A DOCTOR FIRST AND
FOREMOST.
IN ONE SCENE FROM THE VOGUE
POLICE, SHE CRADLES THE ARMS OF
NERVOUS WOMEN AS THEY GET THE
VACCINATION, LOOK AT ME, IT
DOESN'T HURT.
IT'S ONLY KOOL-AID, DRINK THE
WHOLE CUP.
SHE TRIES TO LIFT UP OTHER
PEOPLE.
WHO IS THIS AMAZING WOMAN?
THE SERVANT SAINT HUMANITARIAN
GENIUS MEDICAL MISSIONARY WHO
STILL SOMEHOW HAS MANAGED TO SAY
BEGUILING WE AT 69?
WHAT DID AMERICA DO TO DESERVE
HER?
THANKFULLY, VOGUE ANSWERS THAT
QUESTION.
IT DR. JILL, THE MAGAZINE
DECLARES, IS A JOY MULTIPLIER.
SHE MULTIPLIES JOY, THAT'S WHAT
SHE DOES, IT'S WHO SHE IS.
BY THE WAY, DR. JILL ALSO SHOT
IN 18 ON THE GOLF COURSE LAST
WEEK, PLAYED THE WHOLE ROUND AND
22 MINUTES IN BETWEEN
VACCINATIONS, AND INTERNATIONAL
TREATY SIGHTINGS.
IT WAS A TYPICAL DAY FOR
DR. JOE.
NORTH KOREA THEY MUST'VE READ IT
WITH THEIR OPEN, A JOY
MULTIPLIER?
THAT MIGHT BE TOO FAR, EVEN FOR
THE KIM FAMILY.
NO